what is up everybody at Santa Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving deep into the ruthless
philosophy that is driving the actions
of Eren Yeager the protagonists of
attack on Titan and someone who has
undergone an incredible character
progression from the beginning of the
series up to this point this progression
has been especially drastic in the most
recent arcs of the attack on Titan manga
and this has led to a lot of confusion
in the fandom since a lot of the anime
only fans who still haven't seen the
full extent of this progression tend to
underestimate Eren as a character on top
of that there have been quite a few
posts online that have implied that this
new Eren is a monster a villain or evil
in general some of these posts have
gained considerable traction and in this
video I will be debunking the notion
that Eren is now the villain of the
series I will argue that Aaron's
philosophy is actually far more complex
than many people give it credit for and
I will explain why Eren is still the
hero not the villain of attack on Titan
if you enjoy the attack on Titan content
on this channel and you'd like to see
more you can leave a like to let me know
and if you happen to be new to anime
uproar please don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell heads up
this video will contain attack on Titan
manga spoilers I'm gonna be dealing with
all the latest developments in the story
in order to paint a full picture of
Aaron as a character so please proceed
with caution you have been warned as we
all know a lot has happened to Aaron as
a character after the four-year time
skip and I have entire videos dedicated
just to discussing his actions in
specific chapters such as 120 and 121
but to briefly summarize for a long time
after the time-skip we were led to
believe that Aaron was working with Zeke
and that Aaron and Zeke were heading up
a new yeah giris traction on the island
of paradise
which was determined to make Zeke's
ultimate plan a reality we eventually
learned that Zeke's plan was to use the
founding Titans power to make all living
LD ins infertile which would lead to
every member of the Aldea nation every
subject of aamir essentially dying out
within a generation
Zeke believed that this youth
Asia plan would finally bring peace to
the world because he feels that LD ins
due to their ability to turn into Titans
will always be condemned to suffer in
this world they will always be
distrusted by the other nations and
their Titan powers will continue to
bring them into conflict with everyone
else
leading to an endless cycle of death and
suffering Zeek came to the conclusion
that if he only could mercifully allow
the LDN nation to die out then the world
would be saved but we know from our own
world that his conclusions don't
actually make sense in the real world we
don't have anyone who can transform into
a Titan and yet we still have war civil
strife and suffering I've always felt
that Zeke's plan was both futile and
deeply unfair since he seems to have
internalized the marl and believed that
this generation of LD ins should be
punished for the wrongdoings of their
ancestors even though they themselves
did nothing wrong
however for a long time we were led to
believe that Aaron was fully on board
with Zeke's planned women saw Aaron
fight with his best friends from
childhood Arman and Mikasa and it
appeared as if Aaron decided to abandon
his friends and comrades for Zeke and
Zeke's philosophy nevertheless Arman had
a hunch that this was not really the
case that Aaron merely wanted Zeke to
think that he was on his side and this
was finally confirmed in Chapter 120 of
the manga in Chapter 120 and the
subsequent chapters we realized that
Aaron is opposed to Zeke's plan and that
he has his own unique philosophy that is
incompatible with Zeke's Aaron's
philosophy is ruthless I think that it
could be accurately called Machiavellian
but Aaron's philosophy is not evil
it is not villainous and with the help
of Machiavelli himself I will explain
exactly where Aaron is coming from and
what his ultimate goal is Nicolo
Machiavelli was an Italian political
philosopher who lived in the late 15th
and early 16th centuries he is known for
several important political works
including the prints and the discourses
and his ideas are still highly revered
in the fields of political philosophy
and international relations but just
like Eren Jaeger
after the time-skip Machiavelli has been
greatly misunderstood by the general
public
the very word Machiavellian has become
synonymous with being sneaky immoral and
willing to do whatever it takes to get
your way including lying cheating
stealing and so on if you call someone
Machiavellian in the modern world you
are probably criticizing them and if I
call Aaron's philosophy Machiavellian
you might be tempted to think that I'm
criticizing Aaron and calling him a
villain but this is not the case
Aaron's philosophy is Machiavellian it
is ruthless but it also makes perfect
sense within the ruthless world of
attack on Titan and yes this includes
Aaron's decision to encourage Grisha to
kill Frieda and most of the royal family
something that we learned about in
Chapter one - one of the manga ok so
here's why Machiavelli
is so often misunderstood in the modern
world Machiavelli is known for his
advice to rulers on how to rule their
states or kingdoms especially the advice
he gives in the Prince Machiavelli says
things like it is better for a ruler to
be feared and loved he says that a ruler
must be cunning like a fox and fierce
like a lion and he says that anything
even behavior that may be considered
immoral by the general public is
acceptable if your goal is to preserve
the stability of the state the ruler
must prioritize necessity over
conventional morality and if the
stability of the state is at stake all
methods of preserving that stability are
justified no matter how immoral they may
appear at first glance this principle is
often summed up as the ends justify the
means
although this is not actually a direct
quote from Machiavelli but here's the
thing Machiavelli was not advocating for
immorality and he did not believe that
rulers should be immoral rather he was a
critic of the conventional morality of
his time and he believed in a new and
different kind of morality a morality
that prioritizes different ends than the
more conventional Christian and civic
humanist moral codes of his time in
order to understand Machiavelli's idea
of morality and Eren Yeager's current
idea of morality
we must look at the context in which
these two individuals are living I said
earlier that Nicolo Machiavelli was
Italian and he was in the sense that he
was from the city of Florence in Tuscany
but in Machiavelli's lifetime Italy as a
country did not exist at that time Italy
was divided into many separate states
all with their own interests and agendas
and part of what is modern Italy was
also occupied by foreign kingdoms
including France and Spain the various
Italian city-states were constantly
warring with each other which meant that
Italians were constantly killing other
Italians and this made Italy as a whole
even more vulnerable to foreign attack
and occupation Machiavelli was writing
his ideas in these chaotic times full of
war suffering and betrayal although the
world of attack on Titan is very
different from the real world and it
includes supernatural powers it isn't
hard to spot the parallels between the
chaos war and suffering of Italians in
Machiavelli's time and the chaos war and
suffering of LD ends in the world of
attack on Titan like the Italians and
their states in the 15th century the LD
ends are divided oppressed and governed
by rulers who don't really care about
their own people Machiavelli wanted to
bring about change he wanted to stop the
constant war infighting and suffering of
his homeland he looked around and saw
that the conventional morality of his
time morality that was primarily
influenced by Christian and civic
humanist traditions was not bringing
about the changes that he wanted
Machiavelli rejected the idea that
Italians of his time shouldn't worry
about how badly their homeland was being
governed because their primary concern
should be on being good Christians so
that they could get into heaven he also
rejected the idea that people should
always treat others with kindness and
respect even when those other people
abused your kindness in order to stay in
power for example conventional Christian
and civic humanist principles would say
that you should never kill another
person or steal something from another
person it's right there in the Ten
Commandments thou shalt not kill and
thou shalt not steal but Machiavelli
takes a different approach
he believes that defending one's
homeland and one day uniting Italy in
the way that it was unified under the
Roman Republic is the ultimate goal
to him this goal is true morality not
the individualistic morality of never
killing or stealing under any
circumstances
Machiavelli believes that defending and
unifying his homeland must be achieved
by any means necessary because failing
to do so will result in more Wars and
more suffering for thousands and
thousands of people if you have to kill
in the pursuit of this goal if you have
to steal in the pursuit of this goal
then you should do it
Machiavelli is not saying that you
should be immoral he is saying that what
is happening to his homeland at that
particular time is the greatest
immorality in that sense you can say
that Machiavelli loves his country more
than his own soul and he is willing to
commit what conventional morality
considers a sin if this sin will help
his homeland in the long run according
to Machiavelli a ruler may find himself
in a situation where he needs to be
cunning like a fox and fierce like a
lion where he needs to be feared rather
than loved and where he has to commit
acts that are considered immoral or
sinful according to traditional religion
and conventional morality but if these
things are necessary for the ruler to
preserve stability then he must do what
is necessary allowing the state to fall
into war and chaos just because you
personally want to be seen as a nice guy
is the biggest sin that is true
immorality you are allowing thousands of
others to suffer just so you could keep
your own hands clean if you refuse to
kill one person and that person goes on
to cause chaos and suffering for the
entire country this is a far bigger sin
than killing that person in the first
place this is Machiavelli's new morality
when it comes to rulers he is not
concerned with morality on the
individual level and he is not concerned
with making sure that the ruler goes to
heaven he is concerned with the greater
good of his homeland he wants to stop
the wars the factionalism and the
suffering and he believes that every
virtuous ruler has a duty to do whatever
it takes in order to make that dream
happen in stark contrast to both the
Christian tradition and the humanist
tradition of writers like Cicero
Machiavelli believes that any
action is justified in the name of
preserving the state and its liberty and
this is precisely the philosophy that I
believe eren yeager has adopted in the
most recent chapters of the attack on
Titan manga although instead of 15th
century Italians Eren is concerned with
this generation of LD UNS who are being
forced by both male and their own royal
family to pay for the sins of their
ancestors even though they themselves
did nothing wrong
most people who now claim that Eren is a
villain and evil will point to chapter 1
to 1 and how Aaron encouraged Grisha to
steal the founding Titan power from
Frida even if that meant killing the
entire royal family including the
children who were clearly just
brainwashed how could someone who is
willing to do that be anything other
than a monster of villain just like with
Machiavelli we have to look at the
context in which Aaron makes his
decision King fritz
and through him the royal family
abandoned their own people on the
continent and retreated to the island of
paradise even though King fritz knew
that the LD ins who were left behind
would be brutally oppressed and
mistreated by the marlins King Fritz
then went on to erase the memories of
everyone on the island so that they
would be completely unaware of their own
history and of what was really happening
in the outside world finally King fritz
and his successors established a
repressive police state where everyone
who asked too many questions about the
outside world or challenged the ruling
elite would be brutally tortured and
murdered by the first interior squad
what's more even when their own people
in the island itself were attacked by
the Marlon Titan shifters the royal
family continued to do nothing to help
protect their own people instead Karl
Fritz continued to force his ideology
onto his successors an ideology that
holds that all LD ins deserve to die
because their ancestors did bad things
centuries ago this generation of LD ins
who have nothing to do with what
happened in the past and who don't even
really know what happened are being
mercilessly sacrificed on the altar of
King Fritz's bizarre ideology at this
point in the story Aaron has begun to
reject the idea of conventional morality
from the perspective of an
vidual the idea that he should never
under any circumstances kill another
human being and he decides that in order
to save hundreds of thousands of alien
lives he must sacrifice the lives of the
royal family in order to obtain the
founding titan power Aaron doesn't do
this because he enjoys killing or
because he wants to be evil he does it
because he can no longer stand by and do
nothing while thousands of people are
suffering his own mother was killed in
front of him many of his friends and
comrades were also killed and thousands
more will continue to die unless a
change is made unless the founding Titan
is taken away from the royal family and
a new system is established by any means
necessary the suffering will continue as
much as it is wrong to kill even a
single person Aaron believes that not
taking the founding titan and allowing
thousands of LD ends to keep dying is an
even bigger injustice and I believe that
Machiavelli would completely agree with
Aaron it is interesting how in Chapter
one two one
Aaron emphasizes that ever since he was
born he always wanted freedom he was
always striving for freedom and he is
willing to take away the freedom of
anyone who tries to take his own freedom
away from him this is exactly what
Machiavelli was also concerned with
contrary to popular belief
Machiavelli did not advocate for
authoritarian or tyrannical rule as is
evident in both the prince and his
longer work that discourses Machiavelli
believed that the most stable form of
government was a republic and he advised
all future rulers to establish
Republic's it is also important to note
that in Machiavelli's time republics
were considered to be the most free form
of government they emphasize strong
institutions and checks and balances
which is very different from tyrannical
and authoritarian government but
Machiavelli believed that in the
ruthless world that he lived in before a
true Republic can be created sacrifices
had to be made so for example if the
person who ultimately unites Italy is an
authoritarian leader like say Cesare
Borgia that's fine for now as long as
this leader knows that the best strategy
for stability in the long run
is to establish Republican institutions
interestingly enough
Machiavelli makes multiple references to
Lucius Junius Brutus one of the men
responsible for overthrowing the royal
family of Rome the Tarquins and
establishing the Roman Republic around
the Year 509 BC after Brutus banished
the royal family the former King made
several attempts to overthrow the
Republic and get back into power in fact
during one of those attempts Brutus's
own sons conspired with the royal family
against their father and after they were
caught Brutus allowed both of his sons
to be put to death in order to set an
example and to preserve the liberty of
the newly formed Republic as Machiavelli
puts it anyone who sets up a tyranny and
does not kill Brutus anyone who
introduces self-government and does not
kill the sons of Brutus cannot expect to
survive for long
so if you want to be a tyrant you have
to kill those who love liberty or they
will eventually kill you and if you want
to preserve Liberty you must kill those
who love tyranny and want to take away
your freedom before they kill you
Aaron's decision to kill the royal
family has many parallels to this
principle Brutus was heartbroken that
his sons betrayed him and that they were
now going to be put to death for their
crimes but he couldn't intervene because
he had to ensure the survival of the
Republic similarly I don't think Aaron
enjoyed killing the royal family I don't
think he wanted them to die but he had
to do what he believed to be necessary
in order to save Liberty from tyranny
and in order to save this entire
generation of ldiots from King Carl
Fritz's cruel ideology to save the lives
of potentially hundreds of thousands of
innocent LD ins the lives of a few royal
LD ins had to be sacrificed now I am NOT
saying that we should immediately and
uncritically accept that Aaron did the
right thing in an ideal world no one
would ever have to kill anyone else and
it is definitely not my intention to
justify what happened to the royal
family even if we are talking about just
a fictional anime world but my intention
is to show that Aaron's actions were
driven by a complex
and rational philosophy a philosophy
which has its roots in the writings of
Nicolo Machiavelli this is not as simple
as Aaron doing something bad so he is
now a bad guy the world of attack on
titan has never been simple it has
always made us think it has always
challenged us to look at the world in a
way that isn't just black and white and
whether you support Aaron's decision
whether you oppose it or whether you
just honestly don't know what the right
decision was we have to drop this silly
idea that Aaron is now a villain Aaron
did what he thought was best for this
entire generation of Aldean's he as an
individual did something that is
considered immoral in order to serve
what he believes to be a higher morality
and this higher morality is preserving
liberty and saving the LDN people as a
whole if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more videos like it please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar if
you want to discuss the philosophy of
our Jaeger or any such topics links in
the description and if you want to learn
more about Machiavelli and his
philosophy
I recommend reading his most popular
works The Prince and the discourses in
terms of secondary sources you can check
out quentin Skinner's Machiavelli a very
short introduction and JGA Pocock's the
Machiavellian moment although I will
note that I take some issues with their
interpretation of Machiavelli's
republicanism and I do not consider
these to be perfect or exhaustive
sources on the subject I want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime upper
patrons for supporting our work and
making our videos possible a special
thank you to all of our pro hero to your
patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
King zelgius and on Hell crews on Epic
thank you to all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah Aloha Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Kela and finally at the
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness
at ear reserved only for legends
massive thank you to Reagan Harrison and
Lord Noxon or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon link
in the description even a single dollar
will give you access to our exclusive
patron only discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]